Cô sản này của nó một chống câu phân hoặc gọi này.
Nhanh quan đến việc này, hãy đường chéo đau đau những cửa xú nhăn và kèm phải ý.
Thấy nào bài thắng cho các tổn bè đủ rất là phó chi.
Nên đều biểu của chúng ta nó phải sẽ tương trường hông xa.
Và sẽ tưởng trường trường trường xa.
Bởi vì tưởng trường trường trường trường, mình muốn đau ngàn nó quá,
tự nhiên, cũng để cóm cái tư duy xét nạn xa trởi,
vì giúp đi em mạng, giúp hình tố.
Lâu đặc em sẽ điểm sau to kể kể kể gấp gấp gấp bà này
Mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này, mặc biệt bà này
Hí kếm sẽ thì hợp như mỗi trời của cái game này này, nên qua này kể phép chiến hết